[Musik]
ich hatte früher aus dem
mittelalterlichen gemacht wenn auf den
mittelalterlichen märkten habe ich eine
beleuchtung gebraucht für am main stand
damals gab es keine lateinlehrer
fleschner dann für sechs dass man sich
schon ich habe mir dann selber welche
gebaut aus hobby wenn es einfach für
meine beleuchtung vom stand ja die sind
modern relativ gut gelungen und hatte
die anleihen stand und die leute wollten
nur noch diese latten garten und da
hatte ich aber sagt nee das ist meine
beleuchtung dann kam ich auf die idee
naja wenn sie am bollert anbauen zum
verkauf anbieten nach ich mal mit 56
stück angefangen und die waren auch
wieder ruckzuck allermeisten zlatan gab
und irgendwann ist das so gut geworden
das geschäft das ich gesagt hab ich war
jetzt lang lang
mein name ist joachim schmidt ich bin
der letzte laternen macher deutschlands
der historische holzlatten mit esther
verklausungen herstellt
[Musik]
so
wichtig ist dabei es muss eine liebe zu
dem beruf da sein und das interesse dass
das von herzen kommt um geld zu
verdienen das ist hier in der vollkommen
sekunde sache primär ist immer die liebe
zum handwerk und wenn man eine schöne
arbeit macht und man merkt am ende des
tages man hat was schönes hergestellt da
freut man sich zehnmal mehr als ob man
in den stundenlohn hat für den was 20
euro oder so also der verschleiß und das
herzustellen war sehr groß weil es hat
man niemand gezeigt ich habe mir das
alles selber beigebracht die ganzen
kleinen tricks wie man das glas bricht
das sieht man halt nicht und das muss
man dann üben üben üben bis man richtig
kann
[Musik]
früher als ich verkauft habe wie gesagt
auf mittelalterlichen märkten und viele
kunden haben dann zu mir gesagt auf dem
markt da haben sie nicht eine internet
adresse wo sie das verteilen ein habe
ich nicht und dann habe ich mich bemüht
das zu machen habe mir eine eigene
website selber alles gemacht und ja und
dann habe ich mir was drucken lassen und
habe das dann als flyer mit den kunden
weitergegeben und das muss bis heute
also die laternen sind eigentlich von
der sache her vom vfr querbeet
ja es wird alles gekauft und 50 euro 60
70 80 euro also für eine laterne traurig
ungefähr so zwischen 2 bis mehrere
tausend die kleinen laternen
das sind so zwei stunden zweieinhalb
stunden arbeit
so führt die bleiverglasung nämlich
flott los kapital klaus grün und rot und
dann kommt diese teile noch dazu die
rauten die dann alle in blei eingefasst
werden jetzt schneide ich mal den bogen
wird diese traute und da braucht man
auch einen speziell klaus schneider
und dann wird das angeschlagen
das ist ungerecht
dann habe ich hier eine spezial zange
wohlig die kleinen ecken noch sauber
macht damit dann die bleiverglasung ganz
sauber rein passt so ja ich muss mal
klasse beim gras schneiden dass jetzt
auch das muss ich mal ein bisserl
verletzt es wieder alles heil
so jetzt mache ich mal eine scheibe mit
bleiverglasung das wird dann alles
zusammen gesetzt ich habe da hier im
raum gebaut damit mir das nicht
wegrutscht
und dann kommt diese einzelnen vor
geschnittenen glasscherben sagt man dazu
die können dann hier rein in diesem
rahmen und es muss alles ganz genau
passen
dann muss immer jedes teil hier
angepasst werden
es wird dann um die gebogen dann setzt
man das hier rein und dann muss das
alles angedrückt werden damit erst
richtig anlegt so und jetzt kommt die
nächste scheibe rein und wenn man genau
geschnitten hat es los dann passt das
auch die wird dann leicht angeschlagen
ist zutiefst und skizze kaputt und wenn
so richtig drin sitzt heute noch mal
korrigiert und jetzt kommt dann ihr die
nächste bleiverglasung 1
die nächste glasscherbe genau exakt hier
reinpasst und dann kommt erst das wird
eben zusammengesetzt wie ein puzzle so
und wenn dort genau passt dann hat man
sauber gearbeitet und zum schluss wird
alles angeschlagen damit die das was
über steht beim löten
so jetzt ist die bleiverglasung hasst
man fertig und anschließend wird
vergütet
nicht länger als ein paar sekunden sonst
schmilzt das untere blei und dann ist es
hinüber
so jetzt ist die eine seite fertig das
mache ich das bloß noch sauber damit ich
die säure wieder runter kriegen so ist
im großen und ganzen fertig und dann ist
es so sauber gemacht
sodann habe ich hier die säulen die frau
die atome sind und das nennt man bei uns
die zwischenstücke und dann wird es hier
reingesteckt das muss alles sehr sehr
mäßig sein damit dass zum schluss alles
ganz genau passt wird alles ohne leim
gemacht mit einem stabilen
steckverbindungen so und das ist dann
hier alles geburt hier kommt dann der
einsatz rein für die liste gülle damit
die nicht verrutscht war ja auch viele
nacht west ob bei uns kaufen
und ja man ist das stabil sein damit die
katze nicht umfällt beim laufen die
kugeln bezieht aus dem erzgebirge von
einer drechslerei die auch schon in der
dritten generation arbeitet so jetzt
setzt sich die türe ein
dafür habe ich ein distanzstück damit er
mir chemische rheine mit die tür beim
nageln dann nicht verrutscht
damit so sauber aussieht wenn sie dann
die halbe traum weil die leute früher
damit die sich die finger verbrennen ist
das blech statt drauf
und so sieht sie dann aus wenn sie
fertig ist so eine laterne also jetzt
ohne pleite verklausung hat 249
arbeitsgänge die größte freude ist
eigentlich wenn ein kunde kommt und das
interesse für eine laterne zu kaufen ist
da und ich kann ihm das schön erklären
und wie lange stress stellmach und das
ist dem kunden ein schönes gespräch und
ja verstanden wenn ja schöne zwegat
anerkennung kommt das ist eigentlich
angst
[Musik]
mein sohn ist 12 jahre alt und ich muss
jetzt noch fünf sechs jahre bis zur
rente arbeiten und ich werde natürlich
länger arbeiten es ist klar wo ich denke
mal wenn du in deinen 14 15 jahre ist
werden dann mal langsam an diese
maschinen und diese ganzen arbeit
heranführen und dann war mal sehen was
machen will oder nicht ja und dass das
für die zukunft dann weiter machten es
wäre traurig dass die schweizer zu
machen
[Musik]